very good news for Bernie Sanders he's
got some good news in his life that's
all my Sanders impression is now he
doesn't even speak right that's all it
is
he's like an old orangutan just good
news for Bernie Sanders Oh popular
podcast host Joe Rogan has endorsed
Bernie Sanders for president yeah yeah
yeah Bernie Sanders said that's terrific
and what's a podcast and where am i
right now Michael Bloomberg's in the
news that's come out that Michael
Bloomberg's campaign has been using
prison inmates to make calls on his
behalf yeah it's true just this morning
I got a call from Paul Manafort and
that's for the New York Times hey
Netflix is you know that Netflix didn't
know that they're Gwyneth Paltrow show
the goop lab would feature so many
close-ups of vaginas they didn't know
Netflix said if we had known would have
worded five years ago so now
wait you clearly didn't love the joke
but just applauded vaginas at the end
[Applause]
please got nothing against the vagina
yeah there what zone is a perennial
favorite yeah yeah it's true
how are you pal I'm good come over here
I'm working it you know yeah I'm over
here I'm waiting for you to get done I
know yeah I think they hurt you
we got to go